shot black artists fifty eight blocks
last year but a nice hoop down low
inside yeah what he just did I mean
that's just just now on that block shop
is what he can do well you can get
better in Anna's cups it puts it up that
block swatted into the front room by
Brantley cool nice read right here on
the help side coming over bringing in
turnover same formula watch shot coming
out of nowhere - Scott oh Anderson one
defender is back Boban Oh nicely done
you see they put a defender on yeah
maybe into the late last year block
there by Billy here comes is this a 10
was a nice block by he'll there but what
what what what number does the dunk is
it nine ten what do you think I'm give
him an 8 contain Giordano Pescara Ariel
Helwani with you here by Kumho G there
here comes BJ Dozier the other way
the hammer and the big fella said nope
not happening but as for for sterling
that's what she's supposed to do attack
the big yes yes they are so cokie holden
with the answer he should've just pick
that out there when they get
opportunities Windler average 21 a game
last season's when a senior we red
Belmonte handles it now for cleveland
taking all the way till the window with
the puck as you take a look at what
Windler could do in the open floor and
this one thing you want to see we go
please right now he took his time and
surveyed the corner nearly this is the
to be the epicenter tomorrow Martin on
the other end
watch this play right in stays with the
play helps on the drive and still stays
with the play right there Chris Silva
comes from program where it take you
plays often times yeah interesting top
with another guy that was able to finish
it hit the round like that I think wow a
Burma a meet of primer
Perkins gets through the traffic attacks
for Evan there Simon again this time on
the defensive end he's an elite defender
get healthy he's got to have a little
bit greater impact on this game lock
underneath by gaffer is there a way you
can relieve pressure listen science
seems to be personality
still talking so that's what I love a
healthy Oh shouldn't find a tree I love
a healthy rivalry then we have here at
McCree right there with an excellent
live Vegas
Lonnie Walker and the free doing some
talking give me that
those are time moves when you got a guy
like that you got to finish that cocoon
for Sal's turned away by Aldrich once
and then twice but he gets the foul on
the second attempt to take the ball
behind his head he could a quick dunk
right no if he keeps it in front but
when he took the ball back he gave it
laughs wouldn't fall for him Ranko Joe
I'm up flies in there to wipe it away
back up the Nets up top it's back soon
there's Frank of it's going to work walk
there it's Diop had 17 points in that
first game Seifer on the drive and it
swatted by a co giving off a 29 and 53
season I cook it Shawn take the ball
little joke
the ball getting stuck but all those
things are part of the process where he
was running the floor but Justin Simon
getting in his wave to the deflection
foot play right here don't quit on it
attack it contestants on Euroleague
teens and Spain Italy Lithuania tres oh
my goodness baby spike tax ducts of mr.
Robinson
look at this we'll grab and go for Rjay
and throws it away
Palmer good contest and so there are so
many converging factors they'll get
swatted inside by hall another highlight
for Dante hall to the corner pillow for
the corner three it does not fall
Washington ball gets it ahead
right here Thea what he does he jumps in
the air but he's not trying to foul to
set him up for the block and boy did he
set him up psych just block it Cruz
defense in the final moment big job he
goes up when the shooter goes up that's
very impressive oh they they threw it
away on the out of Bounce smiling geeks
to defend what a block by smiling it's a
dunk on one end and a defensive shot on
the other end of it Poole converts with
the three for a guy who's got to go back
to Serbia to complete his high school
education brain block do it some
educating himself here in Las Vegas
tonight to drive
[Music]
great defense Baisley coming from behind
to deny the dunk sit again right at the
rim
boom Dennis Lindsay that is coming up at
the end of this frame Whitehead splits
the D able to lay it in ferocious block
from John normal playing but man he came
a long way and this is what he done
finally goes back to Phoenix
please go Willie willis gets it take it
away my Grayson Allen
I'm trying for you buddy Grayson Allen
slug to the cup the bucket and an
opportunity for one moles trying to get
back into this game with the Memphis
defense impressive and it's turning into
offense 7156 Chris Shyam it is rejected
by Dante Hall
that was a slap job talk about plant
defense
score the basketball offensive rebound
and wrong with a big rejection on Dwayne
bacon from a set up by bridges watch
this excellent time in all ball look at
that
making this up a we're shifting gears
pivot into them well yeah that's right
you got three Ivy League yeah that's why
I believe guys at the shame Dave is the
love the tremendous anticipation inside
by Boucher that's the elite defender
I've been looking for and then the dish
inside inbound to the block again two
seconds OKC survives without we're
really good defense inside that's not a
foul that defender went straight up
right there now that might be from
pushed mouth but as far as the shot
going up it's not a foul let's shift
away from behind
pick the
Lonnie Brooks Justin Robinson started to
play advil Scofield has that rejected
for a very long time has a lot of
experience you know can handle basically
any basketball
[Applause]
Kenny Wooten with the rejection Barrett
fouled on the other end a man and made
smooth great blocks time out of the
floor
Knicks by box robert pack was a real
good defensive guard he's a good
defensive guard and in a tough
competitor fight over the water can you
talk about good
you got worse alert you know great
volleyball player yeah Wooten is 69
Robinson is seven one Banga let's give
all people playing together
look at that blocks Fran it's nothing
new to see head coaches actually coach
summer league teams we've seen it before
Audra Dawkins tried to put Grayson Allen
in the hole and couldn't just watch this
Oh Grayson said no way kept everybody
engaged that's important
co-op blocked by Allen this fleurs block
of the game out to Josh grade Diop
Murphy with the putback watch Lyle give
taco in general though like I talked to
guys here and they think I mentioned the
report earlier but they think he's you
know a G League type player and let's
see where he goes from there how do you
taco in general though like I talked to
guys here and they think I mentioned in
the report earlier but they think he's
uh you know a G League type player and
let's see where he goes from there how
do you feel about it what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content